[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is I/O Live.
You just saw the keynote where
Sundar and team brought you
through the latest product
and platform innovations
from Google.
They covered Google News,
Android, Google Assistant,
Google Maps, Waymo, and more.
We now have a few special guests
joining us to recap just a few
of the announcements
for developers.
Hi Wayne, thanks for
joining us on I/O '18 Live.
Let's talk about
Google Assistant.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi, Timothy.
Today, we heard about
how the Google Assistant
is becoming more naturally
conversational and visually
assistive.
There's new voices you can
choose from to make the Google
Assistant your own.
We have continued
conversation for more natural
back-and-forth conversation.
We have multiple actions so
you can ask for multiple things
at once.
And we are pretty pleased with
which the Assistant understands
and responds to
polite conversation
with positive reinforcement.
These improvements
really help everyone
have a more natural conversation
with their Assistant.
Also, we unveiled a new visual
canvas for the Assistant
across screens, which brings
the simplicity of voice
together with a rich
visual experience.
I really love the live
demos of this one.
And more importantly
for developers,
Google Assistant is now
on 500 million devices.
It's really easy to build
with Actions on Google.
So if you've been
trying to decide
if you should build Actions
for the Google Assistant,
now's the time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Wayne.
All right, let's
talk about Android.
Dan, there was a lot.
Can you try and
summarize for us?
DAN GALPIN: I'll do my best.
It's great to see us taking
advantage on-device machine
learning at the OS level to
improve battery life and system
health.
Whether that's
anticipating the way
apps are used with
adaptive battery,
we're looking at the way
the brightness sliders used
to help anticipate screen
brightness preferences.
But most importantly
for developers,
you can take advantage
of Android's prediction
by implementing App
Actions, allowing your app
to be surfaced in places
like the Launcher,
smart tech selection in
the Play Store search,
and the Google Assistant.
Slices are something I've
been closely following.
They allow developers to
create an interactive snippet
of their app that can be
searched in different places
in the OS using templatized UI.
For developers who want to
leverage machine learning
within their apps,
we have ML Kit,
which is across platform,
hardware accelerated,
Firebase API that supports text
recognition, face detection,
image labeling, and more.
Users are going
to love what we've
done to simplify things and
help with their digital wellness
in Android.
And developers are going to
love the way Android will
be surfacing their content.
I'm looking forward
to your feedback.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Dan.
Mike, what's going
on with Google Maps?
MIKE PEGG: Thanks, Timothy.
So the mission for Google
Maps for the last 13 years
has been to help you
in the real world
and help people everywhere
in their everyday lives--
mapping every road, every
building, every business
because it matters.
All the great new AI technology
you heard about in the keynote
is really helping us to
make vast improvements
to build on this mission
for our users, things
like automatically
adding addresses
from street view images.
Think about rural places
in Africa or big cities
like Lagos or a dense
urban environment,
places that haven't
been well mapped.
Using this computer
vision technology,
we can look at these
street view images
and literally put new
places on the map.
All this new data will help
developers in these countries
build new location-based
apps for their users.
I'm also really excited
about the new features that
will let you know more
about trending places
based on interests and context.
This is something I know
my wife and I always
struggle with when we're
trying to make decisions
on where to take our kids
for a family dinner out.
Like, what just opened?
And based on our interests
and what we already
like, where should we go?
This will be great for
users and local businesses.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks, Mike.
Check out the description
below for links to get started.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]